it's a gut check it's a you know
who
are you who you say you are and you know
i know this team is i know these players
are i know our coaches are and
you know we we've got so much faith and
belief in sean and everyone else and
i mean we're gonna get right back on
track was it a humbling day for us
absolutely but it's something that we're
going to learn from
we're not going to let it demoralize us
that's a good football team they did a
nice job we didn't do enough
collectively and we'll all look inwardly
and we'll figure out how to be better
moving forward
that was jared goff followed by sean
mcvay after the rams were uh beaten
soundly by the 49ers on sunday 20-7 it
is goats of the week draft goats in a
bad way apparently the younger crowd
thinks goat only means good it doesn't
it means bad and the bad performances
that defined week six coming up peter
king will answer the trivia question to
determine whether he or chris sims will
get the first pick peter the ravens are
on pace to set the record for team
rushing yards in a single season the
current record was set in 1978
by which nfl team
the minnesota vikings
it was the new england patriots who
actually didn't even have one single
player who rushed for 800 yards so it
was spread around i guess steve grogan
chipped in with his horse he wore that
neck roll and was 78 was grogan in 78 i
think grogan was in 78. all right um so
chris you get the first pick all right
well i you know i think if i got to go
goats of the week here i got to start
off with a guy that you know i still
like and got a lot of faith in but baker
mayfield i think is going to lead the
charge for me right away
in cleveland home game big moment
seattle seahawks you know you got them
down 20 to six all those things and it's
looking good uh and then to go on to
throw three interceptions and let
seattle of course come back to win that
football game you know that that's
that's a bad moment i mean those are the
type of games listen i know it's the
seattle seahawks and russell wilson and
pete carroll and how great they are
uh but you'd like to see your
quarterback deliver in those type of
moments to yeah them come out on top and
win the game uh and baker mayfield
whether it was forcing the ball in the
end zone that got intercepted or
throwing this ball to a running back
that was you know two to three feet
behind him hey running backs you got to
put the ball right beneath their chin
right on their numbers they're running
backs for a reason they're not wide
receivers they're not used to receiving
the ball in that capacity uh so as much
as i like baker mayfield and think he's
talented i got to go with him for the go
to the week
peter who you got give me matt bryant
the atlanta kicker who uh i believe just
celebrated his 74th birthday
um
had made 163 of 166
pats
since the nfl moved the p-a-t line back
four years ago
163 out of 166
and he shank epotemus this kick so badly
and forced dan quinn to have a four-hour
flight home wondering whether he was
still going to be the head coach when he
got off the plane he is that might be
temporary but matt bryant is my no doubt
overall in a week of tremendous goats
matt bryan is easily my goat of the week
as the falcons lost by one point that
one point in the desert
yeah that was a stunner and that was a
great game and i i believe the cardinals
were going to win just because the
atlanta defense is so bad but they had a
chance to maybe push it to overtime and
it's on matt bryant that the dan quinn
didn't get one opportunity to win a game
before he's got rams and seahawks back
to back before i think he goes farewell
during the bye week for me i'm going
over to london where jameis winston
uh is inching closer and closer to the
end of his career in tampa bay what a
horrible showing from him with five
interceptions he was sacked seven times
he just yeah all the progress he's made
and and this is kind of how it is for
him the balloon will get blown up
gradually and gradually and all of a
sudden it just pops and it popped big
time on sunday to the point where you do
have to wonder is he going to get
benched at some point this year would
they put blaine gabbert in when
gabbard's healthy but for now winston
still will be the quarterback but he
looked horrible in that game and they
still could have won it was a 37-26 if
he doesn't make all those mistakes if he
gets rid of the ball faster if he avoids
the things that gerald mccoy knew he was
gonna do like step up in the pocket
repeatedly and set himself up for those
hits
it may have gone differently but that
that's uh it feels like that's it for
jameis winston even though
uh he's still gonna have some chances to
try to turn this thing around yeah it
wasn't pretty certainly uh you know i do
think you know he was under tremendous
pressure so i i want to give him a
little benefit of the doubt there but
yeah that was ugly and it's just still a
little bit of an unawareness at times
with people around them and when to just
say you know know when to hold them and
no one to fold them and he just doesn't
know when to fold them sometimes
okay my second goat of the week would be
zach brown uh the ex-linebacker for the
philadelphia eagles the guy that talked
all that crap about kirk cousins and
that he can't beat you and blah blah
blah blah blah okay and then oh yeah oh
yeah he can't beat you well he torched
your ass i'm pretty sure on sunday so he
can beat you and then you know to add to
it
you know to not want to answer questions
about it after the game and be annoyed
that people i'm sick of this from
players they got to stop this you can't
say stuff and then be like what are you
talking about media how dare you
question me on this i mean
damn i mean i just you can't do that you
can't be mad that the media wants to ask
you questions about crap you said and
need to be accountable for and now it's
been thrown back into your face and you
don't want to talk about it no then
throwing the challenge challenge flag
allen river on said that's bs and you
can't do that that's against the man
rule the football rules all of it he
should have been maybe my first pick but
i didn't think you guys would go there
so i sandbagged you
that's not a bad pick you know mike my
my second pick is going to be marcus
mariota
um and i'm gonna i'm gonna dovetail a
little bit on what you talked about i
mean first of all his stats in the game
were horrible and he got yanked you know
seven of 18 63 yards no touchdowns two
picks
and this continues a four and a half
year trend
that for every one game that you see
marcus mariota play that just say man he
looks like the long-term answer he'll
give you three games where you say
there's no way we can give this guy a
second contract
and whereas i think it is still
maybe
55-45 yes that the bucks right now as of
today
give jameis winston another contract not
a long one but another contract to be
their starter sort of a bridge contract
i think the tennessee titans are going
to shake hands with marcus mariota after
this year give him his gold watch and uh
and wish him the best and he's going to
be gone yeah yeah he got yanked for ryan
tannehill at denver we felt it coming a
couple of weeks ago in that thursday
night game against jacksonville it
didn't happen then it finally has
occurred and mike rabel the coach of the
titans do to be announcing soon who the
starting quarterback will be
this weekend not that it's making much
of a difference for the titans after
that great win week one against
cleveland they are one and four all
right i'm going to stick with the
quarterback theme i mean when i saw that
jared goff had 78 passing yards against
the 49ers i thought it was a typo i
thought it was a misprint i thought
there was a one or a two or a three
missing but 78 yards and i know he was
under relentless assault all day long
but just like we said with jameis
winston you got to make quicker
decisions you got to get rid of the
football and i think what really
uh was underscored on sunday when you
take away the threat of todd gurley even
though todd gurley isn't a workhorse
anymore when you take away the threat
that is always there because todd gurley
does still have a high level of skill
that made it easier to tee off on jared
goff to cover the receivers and to not
have to worry about the running game and
when you're not worried about the rams
running game jared goff looks pretty
darn ordinary and the difference between
the rams the bucks and the titans is the
bucks and the titans can still avoid
paying big money to winston and mariota
the rams have already paid the big money
to golf yeah uh i had a feeling when you
know you guys might go there i i and you
know i man it really ruined what i
wanted to do here with my next pick
because i really wanted to make the rams
offensive line my go and you know what
i'm still gonna do it as a hell with
your pick florio okay i'm gonna make the
rams offensive line i
understand what you're saying i get it
you like your franchise quarterback to
make a few plays and do things like that
but still i just got to say something
about that o line you know they just got
absolutely obliterated and steamrolled
in that football game uh in the run game
in the pass game i mean it didn't matter
if it was havenstein whitworth the
interior offensive lineman they all took
turns getting their butts whooped
yesterday so i'm not trying to argue
your your jared goff point but either
way that was a pitiful showing by them
they were completely dominated in both
phases run and pass protection and the
49ers that was a big reason they they
won the football game they just did not
match the physicality uh of that 49ers
front and that was that was a a a huge
thing
you know the i i i want to give this my
last goat and and i'm going to i'm going
to sort of carpet bomb the entire
officiating crew
of clete blakeman's crew in last night's
game
because i think
there were enough calls in the game
including uh two lousy calls of phantom
calls again
in the first half of this game and then
obviously in the second half the two
phantom trey flowers penalties and you
know i know that after the game blakeman
spoke he said they were the fault of the
umpire who threw those flags but i just
look at this an officiating crew is a
team effort and that was a bad team
performance by that crew so i'm giving
it to the entire cleat blakeman crew for
the game at green bay last night
yeah and and uh i think that's a good
call because there were too many bad
calls and they didn't even out aaron
rodgers said well the bad calls even out
over the years they definitely did not
even out last night the packers got the
benefit now i'm struggling with my last
one
um i i still want to go back to pat
shurmur from last thursday because i'm
still
[Laughter]
it's mind-boggling that he punted on
fourth and two down 14 with seven
minutes left in the game just to avoid a
bad headline that he lost by 21 and he
still lost by 21 but that was thursday
let's focus on the weekend that was i
got to give it to anthony lynn
um hey you know i i wanted to pick
somebody from the chargers i was going
to go phillip rivers and and you could
go but ultimately the coach is the one
who's got to get the team ready and that
team just wasn't ready for a prime time
game a big game
and and and i think anthony lynn is a
great coach and he should have gotten
greater consideration last year for
coach of the year and i think he can
still turn it around and we hear all the
time about how great his coaching staff
is it just feels like the chargers week
by week are not ready to play they
weren't ready to play against the
broncos they weren't ready to play at
home against uh the steelers and and i
just don't understand how a team that
went 12-4 last year has all of a sudden
lost it and i just i feel like that game
that we saw on sunday night one team was
ready to play and the other team was not
mike tomlin had his team ready anthony
lynn did not and so i got i gotta make
anthony i and i do it reluctantly
because i like the guy and i think he's
a great coach and he shouldn't be
anywhere close to the hot seat but
performances like last night that's
going to get you on the hot seat guys
yeah definitely is i i think we all blew
it by not picking the chiefs defense too
that's the another one that would have
probably put in there i mean it's two
weeks in a row they can't even get you
know the mvp of football on the field in
the second half
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports